[Music]
you made it weird with Pete Holmes
what's happening weirdos it is the
return and the first video episode with
my dear friend Andrew Santino this was
effortless I'm looking to Katie we were
both talking about how fun this episode
was how funny he is he was even I think
he said he was tired and he just turns
it on we laugh like silly sillies and we
had a blast and I'm really excited that
you guys are here if you would like to
come and see me doing stand-up comedy
you have a few options if you're in La
I'm going to be at Largo on October 9th
that's coming up on Sunday and I'm also
going to be there November 3rd November
3rd is going to be a fundraiser for
Homeboy Industries which I'm very
excited about but both of those shows
are going to be stacked we're going to
get great guests great musical guests
it's always the highlight of my month go
to
largo-la.com for tickets and if you want
to see me I'm going on the road go to
petehomes.com for tickets I'll just read
some of the Cities October 14th Toronto
the 5th 15th Atlantis Atlantic City New
Jersey October 16th I'm at The Wilbur in
Boston that's like about 70 percent sold
I believe so please if you want to come
to that one in my hometown get tickets
these are also now available on the
website Chicago San Francisco Portland
Seattle Atlanta Charlotte and Washington
D.C uh please come on out I think Andrew
and I talk about touring quite a bit uh
so this this is
this is the one to come to I'm not
saying I'm retiring I'm just saying
let's make this a great one
I'm not retiring I'm never gonna stop
doing stand-up but come on what this one
do this one go to peterhomes.com I'm
super excited about this hour I'm super
proud of it so hopefully I will see you
there and if you like the show why not
try a pizza pick these are what we call
the ads these are things that I love and
I use especially with without a doubt
for real for real living Libations
living Libations is a natural and real
ingredient skin hair teeth eyes baby
body care company that is revolutionized
all of those things and changed the way
that I look at health and what I put on
my body I was being very careful about
what I was putting in my body trying to
eat natural real organic things but I
wasn't being careful about what I put on
my body but of course what you put on
your body ends up in your body your skin
is the largest organ it absorbs that
stuff into your bloodstream so we
shouldn't be be putting strange
chemicals and and health beauty products
sunscreens uh lotions stuff that isn't
intended for humans if you read the
ingredients and it's like seven Z's and
the number Act and the number Z that
can't speak today and the number 28 just
think of any number Pete and that bit
works it's probably not good for you but
I was fooled by branding and by
marketing thinking that these things
were good because they had French names
I want to eat food where I recognize the
ingredients and now I want my skin care
to be the same so enter living Libations
a great example is their love design
love the sun zinc based sunscreen every
morning our daughter we have to slather
her head to toe in sunblock and I saw
there were natural quote unquote natural
things on Amazon and they just weren't
like if you dug a little bit deeper and
read the ingredients these were not
healthier sunscreens and I was so happy
to find the living Libations love the
sun sun formula that is what we put on
Leela every morning it's great to know
that I'm not putting something unnatural
or bad for her on her body of course at
four years old that's super important
and me personally I use their Ginger
exfoliating scrub which is not only
healthy and natural and made with
ingredients that I recognize but it's
the most badass exfoliant that I've ever
used in my life and at night I use their
uh their what is it called
best skin ever moisturizer smells great
feels great and gets your skin looking
great of course I use theirs and shave I
use their gum treatments a lot of their
Dental stuff and when Lila was a baby we
used tons of their baby stuff here's the
point if you want to support the show
living Libations has small products and
big products if you want to give a
little if you want to give a lot you can
get something small you can get a tongue
scraper do whatever you want it still
supports the show it lets our
advertisers know that these ads are
working and you'll be doing your body a
favor whatever product you'd like to
replace I promise you living Libations
has a premium natural and wonderful
product to replace the random chemical
nightmares that they sell at 7-Eleven so
go to livinglibations.com and use promo
code this is new for this month weird
2020 2022 weird 2022 that's 15 off go to
livinglibations.com and use promo code
weird2022 also we are brought To Us by
our friend at ritual I take ritual
multivitamins I take ritual symbiotic
plus pre-post and probiotics every
single morning I'm super super into
Health feeling my best feeling ready to
start my day and gut health and their
symbiotic plus pre-post and probiotic is
the best probiotic I've found I always
always start my day with it and here's
here's I'll tell you a little I'll tell
you a little bit more about it does your
probiotic contain clinically studied
strains well meet one that does ritual
symbiotic plus contains two of the
world's most studied strains with over
350 publications of human clinical
trials it's more than a probiotic three
in one as I mentioned with clinical
studied prebiotics which are like food
for probiotics probiotics and a
postbiotic to support a balanced gut
microbiome which we sometimes talk about
on the show is so important your gut is
basically like a second brain and
regulates so many of the functions of
your body so important to give it what
it needs and here you can do that with a
single nested minty capsule I love the
minty flavor one daily capsule for a
simple streamlined gut support and the
delayed release capsule makes sure that
these uh pre-post and probiotics reach
the colon that's not the stomach they're
going to burn up in the stomach the
delayed release make sure they get into
your intestinal tract which is the ideal
place for probiotics to survive and grow
there's designed with moisture
controlled bottle technology to provide
to protect excuse me the probiotic
strains and best of all you don't have
to refrigerate them I keep it right in
my cupboard and they stay good so
symbiotic and ritual are here to
celebrate not hide your insides there's
no more shame in your gut game that's
why ritual is offering uh weirdos 10 off
during your first three months visit
ritual.com weird to start ritual or add
symbiotic plus to your subscription
today that's ritual.com weird for 10 off
during your first three months and show
your support of the show alright guys go
to petehomes.com for the tour dates hope
to see you at Largo if you're here in
the LA area in the meantime enjoy the
hilarious whiskey Ginger
Andrew Santino
get into it topic topic of conversation
number one you don't want to do this get
in here get in here
I'm so tired you felt that was a thing
you didn't want me to take your hand
well because I didn't do my hair I
didn't get well look I didn't get out of
it I got out of the shower I haven't
done it I want to apologize
to you go for it let me apologize to you
I'm sorry go for it it made me hurt
thank you
I'm just tired and you know what it is
and I have a pimple on my lip and I put
makeup on it I went to the I went to CVS
and I got because cbs.com whiskey
cvs.com
for 10 off some of your makeup Goods but
I put a little bit of um tinted
Clearasil I put up some stuff on it and
then it makes it worse and then you're
like it looks like I have a canker sore
and then you're like I don't have a
canker sore I don't get canker sores
those are herpes well I have herpes on
my penis but not on my mouth that's
insane we'll be right back it's a
herpes.com
right now does that work does voucher I
thought they were I don't care for herbs
no no no I think it subsides some of the
um flare-ups yeah but I just I got
annoyed by it and then I I
I was so mad because
um God have I been shooting too much
what are you doing you're pickling up
your gingers I'm doing Dave season three
uh the ding dong show I gotta tell you
something these Jews caught and
stop it stop it
yeah oh Pete cut it out
peace
[__] [__] I forget how high it is
paint paint you got a high to do Bill
that's a [__] Slight Return [__]
oh God
that's my Park Fenway Park sold it out
did the Red Sox can't do that no they
can't
it's amazing how does that feel like do
you want to do amphitheaters and
stadiums yeah sounds like a nightmare to
me I get a big two I just shot my
special in Denver Colorado
also tired and I'm gonna be real with
you because sometimes we get very real
you and I
hold that there
I don't want to do stand-up anymore
buddy I was just on the phone today with
myself exhausted and after I shot the
special I said go ahead go ahead hit it
like it's Stand Up Hit It Like It's
stand up and it oh and it opens always
in your life but it always comes back
into my life just like stand up I just
think I just shot it in Denver I had a
fun time shout out to Denver I had so
much fun but also you know what [__] Dad
I'm just kidding Denver thanks for
coming out see we're chills chills too
rowdy well you know ever since they
legalized the The Tender Greens
I remember doing the high plains
Festival the first year they legalized
The Tender Greens
that's how you have to say it when you
walk in a store do you guys have any
Lego sir get out
you take a walk around the block come
back what's MDMA do you have any yeah
that's cocaine oh MDMA is you guys yeah
and you have to touch your neck that
sound yeah you have to rub your titties
rub your titties men have them women
have them we have them I have boob
Shadow you can see it in photographs do
you really must go look at that I have a
new bed can I run it by you down yeah go
ahead keep it up no no put it down I
just started everybody knows this
lifting weights okay it turns out
it's not a You're Nobody you're nobody
special Muscle Boy no I know all you did
was that I did a lot more than you did
though yeah that's who who cares more
than you Society is all about more than
you yeah that's okay bigger house bigger
car more than money that's what we I
just do this more but you weren't
fighting off wolverines in my mind I was
in my mind I was fighting off a lot of
demons so if you curl the heavier weight
you curl the more you can ward off Crow
means lift
that's just how it goes the more
Wolverines you can ward off yes I'm just
saying for those of us not you let me
tell you why I want to live you had a
weight a white baseball cap in high
school let's be honest white baseball
cap white baseball cap white baseball
cat boy baseball cat boy baseball cap
white baseball cap one of my favorite
Death Cab songs yeah white baseball cap
very good he put out a new song the
other day and I listened to him Gibbard
the Gibbs dog
and it just at this point in my life I
don't want to hear it anymore
it's music I want to be real with you
because we're getting tired of it we're
circling we're waiting to be cleared to
land this conversation plane yeah at the
terminal marked is it time to hang it up
is it time to hang it up I just on the
drive down called my friend Rob Bell
okay he's an author and a teacher he's a
genius and I called him because I did a
set at The Improv two nights ago and I
called him and I was like Bob Bobby I'm
tired of this thing that I'm doing with
stand up when it gets me high when I
have a great set and everybody's like
I'm like that was great and if it sucks
I'm like what am I doing you know and
I'm like I I talk to some people and
they're just they seem so Noble they're
just like I just love making people
laugh I travel around the land and make
them laugh and I'm like Michael Jordan
I'm like I'm out there for me I want to
spin and dunk and have new shoes and be
shiny and fancy and like that game is
becoming less interesting to me I'm
going to say something strange the more
more healed as a person I become I have
less compulsion to go out and earn it in
front of strangers of course stand up is
becoming I'm go I'm on tour currently
but like it's becoming hilarious
well no [__] might be one it might be
the last time I'm not saying that to
threaten anybody I don't think it's
gonna be but I do think it's so you
don't think it's gonna be no I think
it's okay to feel that way always feel
this way you're we're having that
conversation where you're like you don't
leave your wife you don't leave your
wife but you do if she pisses you off
enough if it just becomes sometimes
standing tell me what you're thinking
okay you know what I really think it is
it's not just your age and you're
settling into mediocrity you can say
mediocrity it's just settling into who
you really are but it's not just that as
a media mediocre man I just really
believe that it has a lot more to do
with
um
the time stand up is about what's
happening right now uh and it's changing
like Ryan Stout you know him great
comments yeah he just had a tweet that
said uh
something that's effective like I'm so
jealous of comics I get like full
high-res videos the first like three
times they've ever done stand up sure
he's like we just have to [__] call a
club oh yeah beg if they could allow
recording equipment set up a Handycam on
a try which would get knocked over or
stood in front of by someone's big fat
dog head for 20 minutes yes and he's
like we had to do that like getting a
tape quote unquote was an impossible
feat Sandman impossible Sandman I have
VHS tapes oh yeah that I'm like this
sweet it had to be good enough yeah
just so they could hear enough of this
[__] and kind of see you and then
they're like maybe we'll let you be on
TV that's right most of the time no can
I throw you something you're gonna know
what I'm gonna get it you're gonna get
it give it you've already signed for
this package
it's like a David Blaine is it included
yeah David Blaine works for FedEx he
goes can you sign this and you look at
him you've already signed up and you
look up and he's the package David and
you open it and he's in there oh no and
then he asks you to sign again and this
time you have inside
honestly he must get [__] what we're
talking about he's like what do I got to
do you eat a living goat and [__] it out
and it's a donkey yeah and we're like
yeah you have to go up you're almost die
is what they want all performers to do
yeah make yourself almost die for us for
me we're back to Gladiators yes we are
we almost die okay here's what I'm gonna
say tape anxiety
the curse of the tape can I tell you
what is what we hold my hand old
Old-Timers so sad right now though also
because the Denver taping man it was so
fun but also knowing you're taping it's
the worst it's the worst it it's so hard
because you're in your head you're like
this is locked down Forever This is the
version this is the one that they have
that they get to see not the one that I
did last week that I kind of changed in
Minneapolis that I liked a little bit
that it hurts man hold hands again yeah
I completely know what you mean okay and
the whole thing I when you're doing a
special it's all about that second show
it is you do the first one and you get
it then the nerves are gone then the
second one you maybe do it well but
maybe you don't maybe you don't and
sometimes it just no it went good it's
just also it went well you know I've
told this story uh on another podcast
uh well just plug it then all right uh I
don't think he's doing it anymore oh wow
how I propose well I think it was Ron
Jeremy I think he's in trouble I didn't
do his podcast that's insane
um I did no I didn't Jeremy in trouble
he's in prison is he what you don't did
that go over your head Ron Jeremy is a
bad bad boy I don't know anything about
it bad boy he's a bad boy he got in
trouble not like a Will Smith uh Martin
Martin Martin Martin
Lawrence Martin Sheen new movie Martin
Sheen uh Will Smith coming out really
good called the slapper slap him up
smack him around after I did my half
hour for Comedy Central Pete yeah cried
like a baby sorry I'm still thinking
about a Will Smith commercial parody
called the slapper where he turns off
the lights by slapping somebody twice
the slapper it's a new millennium and
then that's like that's a good Will
Smith do it again
no it was a bad Will Smith nobody
thought it was good it was a bad Will
Smith I can't do well Jay Pharoah just
did this he did Will Smith and when he
does it you didn't know that Will Smith
sounded like something so Will Smith
sounds how does Will Smith sound do you
remember I asked Katie to do it I can't
do Will Smith
I can do that yeah
big wheelie style that's good not bad
Uncle Phil hey Uncle Phil that's closer
hey Uncle Phil on Viv hey I'm Viv
um not as good Phil was better well hot
wings I don't know Hooters that's what
they do yes they were sponsored by
Hooters Fresh Prince of Bel-Air
sponsored sponsored by Hooters you know
my dad was so embarrassed to say Hooters
back home when we drove uh we were
driving down one of those Frontage roads
and there was a Hooters over there and
he goes make a left the freeway is up
it's the old exit's closed he says you
got to go over there by the uh the
chicken joint and I was like
whatever it is like whatever it is he
acts like he doesn't know liar
I cried after I did my half hour was
what I was gonna say yeah tell me
because I hated every second of it
because because of that no you know who
I did my half hour the same night as oh
Ryan's out keep going did you really
yeah I think it was all the pressure
that finally gets left you know like it
just Falls and then the moment you get
off stage you're I was like I [__]
hated every second of it but I actually
really liked it the way it came out yeah
but it just bummed me out for some
reason all the things make you have you
seen the movie Soul
yeah remember when he plays with wasn't
my favorite of the pixars I don't wanna
I don't know why I'm whispering this but
I agree yeah but um because we're not
allowed to say that because people will
go what are you racist and you're like
yeah but that does nothing to do with
soul I didn't see that coming I really
didn't see the race thing coming in how
many other black lead Pixar movies are
there I consider Nemo to be
African-American
hot name alone just the name alone
sounds like one of the Jackson Five he
does there's Tito there's Michael there
is Nemo we could never find him yeah
where is he's never shown up for
rehearsal so stupid if this is the joke
that brings us both down Fine honestly
at this point at this point post Denver
you want to know who's got a real
disgusting sense of humor Pete Holmes
he's out there doing Michael Jackson
Finding Nemo minority related poor joke
trash
taping is so hard is what I'm trying to
say it's just people don't get
whenever somebody goes uh I didn't like
the special it just blah blah blah
you're like do you love the comic yeah I
like him I just didn't like the specials
like well then just hold on to the fact
that you like the comic because specials
are so hard to formulate I completely
agree they're just so difficult
for me and I want to hear you yeah
I'm always trying to optimize the Pete
that shows up the night of the special
but really at the end of the day the
older I get the more I realize I'm not
in control yeah and there really is a
dice a roll of the dice element to like
boy I can try to get psyched up and get
excited or whatever but if there's just
something that could be food it could be
sleep it could be sex it could be no sex
it could be uh a nap that went a little
too long and now I'm on stage going I'm
uh I don't [__] care and I just I I
want to do that a little bit that's why
I feel like we kind of want to you want
to stop sometimes because you're like
oh it so much goes into it and I know
it's like boom you're crying remembering
this issues oh you don't stand up no but
honestly it's just I don't think people
get houses safe it's so difficult during
the pandemic oh no during this pandemic
that's what it was for I created it
during the stand up again gentlemen the
sand Demi the pandemic is huge Anderson
it's huge you have to get a Santino shot
[Music]
whiskey Ginger I don't drink I just have
the whiskey I mean the ginger imagine he
just he listens to my podcast he loves
it love the show
too many gays on there too many gays and
non-whites
he's like the snake from uh what's that
movie it's where he's the Aladdin yeah
that little sneaky snake the little
sneaky snake we're also serpentor
wait serpentos
yeah
did you see that he looked like Liberace
he's wearing a golden snake and he plays
a piano with his head
and he spoke with kind of like a snaky
list he did is that not saying Liberace
had a sneaky list yes he did okay no he
didn't
do you remember Liberace what he sounded
like nobody knows what Libra is Naval
Liberace song Let Me Liberace candelabra
is that her I have no idea
um many ring piano candelabra that's his
hit yeah that was his thing the
lottering fancy piano playing can we
talk about Ojai yeah
boy oh boy is that cool that you live up
there really it's so neat I'm pleased
there's one other friend I have that
lives up there who
the singer no the comedic actor I know I
know it's a that's a tough name
it's a tough name hey Pete what are you
doing up an old Holland I didn't know
you had a 10 out of 10 Michael McDonald
can I tell you one I want to see you
Pete this is this was one of my earliest
bits was do you think Mike McDonald
after he lays down the track goes out
and was like dude you guys well I can't
do it nearly as well do you think that
was real good
he lives up by you my buddy Michael
McDonald he was on Mad TV you remember
him I I bet the second I see him I'll
remember him and I'll write him up he's
he stayed up there for a while Jay
Larson was just there and he told me
another comedian that lives up in Ohio
but dude I'm gonna tell you one thing
because I'm I'm interested that you
you're into it yeah
uh there's a lot of energy in this town
too much and it turns out that uh I'm
very sensitive to the energy and when I
get out of it very good for Petey I
think that's a good healthy way to look
at my buddy just on the phone with my
buddy and he was saying how he
stopped all social media and he was like
I'm done I was like no way he's like I'm
done I'm also off social media but he
deleted all of it it's all gone oh I
just hired someone to run it for me yeah
please do follow me
so you know he's all done what Jake is
posting and I understand that just be
done with it sometimes I think we're
moving into a really uh interesting time
what we were saying before about the
time of stand up
I think stand-ups lost its um
the hum is different now and so like the
cultural hummus you turn the machine on
and it goes like when stand up was at
its peak culturally with like like fun
hum socially it was like hum dumpster
and now it's just like
it's too much like I I think I looked to
Katie who was listening it is a little
over Everything feels over oh like
heavy-handed now I don't I think it's
the Earth it's just everything it's hard
for us to talk about it when you're like
everything's kind of annoying and and
black and craziness it could be look I
think and parasocial relationships are
ruining us tell me we're done what do
you mean uh in-person contact has become
so odd now because parasocial
relationships everyone is your friend on
the internet can I
here's a new BET new Prem give it to him
premise yeah
um I have a palette Val has a Peloton I
was gonna say you don't know about
Peloton old homes he started using it
though because Val doesn't like it why
didn't she like it well she was trying
to ride it like a real boy
foreign
[Music]
[Laughter]
old homsy has a Peloton anatonal and
both of those are things that what are
tonal tonal is like a Peloton but for
weights yeah I love it actually you'd
like it you'll [__]
yeah [__] is that plugged into the wall
or connected to the wall I've seen those
that's cool it's like a it's like one of
those mirror screens
yeah yeah and you can move them any way
you want and how strong could you have
to be to to it goes up to 200 something
200 pounds that's pretty good for a wall
thing it's also heavier than that
because it's it's each arm is
independent I could this is how about
this though I know you didn't put it up
you had somebody put it up you can't put
it up yourself why tonal policy it's
tonal's policy you can't install it
yourself they won't let you do it you
can't check the box I'm Bob Vila I will
install this myself what if he wants to
what if Bobby wants to so they send but
they send it to your house
dude listen if you're gonna put
something on your wall into the studs
and then all you're ever going to do to
that thing is try to pull it off the
wall with all your Force
[Laughter]
yeah that's that's a million lawsuits
waiting to happen so they make it sound
like they're doing you a nice thing like
white glove installations included but
really it's like no lawsuit installation
is included the Peloton got in trouble
that's because they don't have any um
installation they're like they deliver
it to you and you're like you put it
together and also people go too hard on
it well I think what like a little kid
got
oh yeah I saw a little safety mechanism
to stop it from
getting someone caught in it oh really
yeah what would that look like a
mosquito net over it
some sort of netting you guys don't have
kid cages at the house it's just mobile
cages that you move around objects that
you don't want them to put it around
everything the fridge if he's if he's
snacking too much we put a kid total
policy kid cages
sometimes you leave a kid inside
[Music]
I am serpenter I am
serpenter wow we found out Donald Trump
is actually serpenter of the snake for
per the cheese maker from the Italian
Liberace gold snake man from GI Joe of
the 80s this whole time it turns out
that was Donald Trump
it was serpentour I was also a Cobra
Commander beautiful mask gosh let people
see therefore than we know I guess yeah
true and he was also Dr claw go back
um so Ojai no no you walk around Ojai I
want to tell you the bit then we'll get
back to Ohio don't forget we won't
forget Ohio okay here's the bit because
I'm so interested in that when I'm on
the Peloton yeah and they're like Crank
It Up to 50. put the resistance to 50.
50 pounds of no no I don't know what
what it is oh it's a fake it's in it
it's a number it's it's normal
resistance would be 35 would be like a
moderate isn't that funny that number
means nothing it means nothing but
they're allowed to just they can start
it at 400. so did the Mayans make an up
zero [__] some guys drinking
chocolate goes what if there's a number
that means no numbers and they're like
this guy is a [__] genius let's play
elbow ball and kill the team that loses
am I in Italians
there was one Italian in every culture
oh for sure oh my God we should be
worshiping cats over here yeah that was
Egypt I'm going over the river of death
over there why don't you do me a favor
and build yourself a great wall
if it's so great where's that moves
around
does it keep my mother-in-law out
oh no Jesus saying she's a savior I love
her I love you Mary I love you I love
you Marion you're all merry let's be
clear you're everyone to you is Mary
um crank it up to 50. the Peloton person
so old homes he's sweating this is
important okay I try to do did you know
30 minutes of cardio is as effective as
Prozac I'm screaming this is from real I
just added my brain scan and the doctor
was like if you elevate your heart rate
for 30 minutes it's the same as me
putting you on Prozac what if I plummet
it down below what does that do when I
get it if you don't move at all that's
the same as being on Vicodin
[Music]
and he loves Vicodin eating a bag of
jacks that's Vicodin so you gotta juice
up your mind for 30 minutes a day yes so
I juice up the bod I get out I got it
it's a good anti-depree so I get on it
for Auntie Dupree got it uh and the
teacher who is a video this is your
parasocial relationship thing I know
she's not really there so when she goes
let's crank it up to 40. I just got now
I go I'm already sweating I'm getting a
workout why why would I listen to a it
would it would be like listening to a
YouTube video oh see I'm such an idiot I
would do it you would oh my God I'm
cranking I'm afraid she's gonna know I
didn't do it you are going to be ranked
lower at the end of it and I'm just
going to go
you storm out do me a favor I could use
the internet heat storm how you [__]
drinkers
I'm out of here there it is
put petehomes.com on the screen with the
tour dates
well I got mad at the um I got mad I did
Orange Theory but I'm not plugging but I
did Orange Theory
um is that a philosophy class you taught
yeah it's my philosophy class the theory
of Life by an orangeman no it's like a
it's like a social workout class and you
do you do rowing and biking and lifting
and all this stuff and they put your
stuff up on the screen and people aren't
finishing the workouts so it's not your
level of like heart rate and output and
calories burn they want to be first so
they want to be done first but it'll be
like you know 35 uh up downs and then 15
seconds Sprint and then but people
aren't you on 35 up downs or they're not
doing a row for two minutes they're in a
row for half a minute why wouldn't it
because they want to be done before
everybody else oh it doesn't because it
doesn't tell it'll it can't clock like
how many push-ups or sit-ups that you do
it's only clocking your heart rate and
calories burned but they want to be
moved up in the timing of of like how
quickly they're moving on to the next
station so they say they're done yep and
it's bothered me so much
and so I never went back again because I
was like I'm doing every single one and
I was more fit than almost everyone in
the class well and they were all way
ahead of me time wise I was like that's
impossible because they figured out how
to cheat you know they were cheating the
system and then it worked and then they
then they just they felt better about
being in first because they couldn't
physically be in first huh to me once
I'm sweating I just want to stay
sweating and stay efforting is that a
word no but you're efforting so here you
are efforting out you're sweating and
Val is cheering you on and Val is there
she's cooking a pot roast I'm like honey
not now
and I go as long as I'm getting a
workout I'm fine but some people would
listen to the robot I listen to the
robot I don't listen to the robot yeah
but that's why you're in Ojai yeah
that's right and that's why I'm still in
the mad house of Los Angeles
the robot has told me to stay right foot
even like the when the watch is like
close your circles I'm like eat a [__]
dick like I don't I don't [__] work
for you sir you're a [__] dick thank you
I love a dick man it's actually
horseshit is it really it's mostly hair
now it's better for you not even gross
it's just fiber it worked for the horse
it's not only fiber it's fiber that you
know worked it worked it cleaned out
that horse you eat it shape of a dick
you [__] it yeah Human Centipede [__]
dick commercial please
19.99.com
whiskey Ginger whiskey uh 16 off I
sometimes say 10 added to your bill so
yeah we got out do you and the lady
think about getting out
and I really do want to know if you're
going to quit stand up because this is
that's a hot top I don't think I'm gonna
I just think I wanna walk for a while I
just wanna get on them I just
meanwhile I'm supposed to do New Year's
Eve but that's like a party show New
Years yeah New Year's rocket named me
and Dick Clark he's back he's back they
just have him propped up
yeah
almost no effort almost no effort I'm
doing a new year show in Boston I'm
doing New Year's Eve just because I was
like that'll be a fun yeah it those
things are wild and stupid and fun but
but I was like I don't want to do any
dates for a while like literal dates for
a while I also have enough I don't have
anything I dumped everything and I vowed
that I'm not going to do any of that
stuff ever again after the taping I'm
done people are like well you can still
do it before it comes out and I'm
literally done I said to myself mentally
don't it's over any of that stuff again
well I do think there's you need to have
some infinite potential you need some
spaciousness is what Rob told me too you
need some like wide open like
free-falling not not knowing what you're
gonna do and then something exciting
will enter your life I also had a
depressive week because I wanted this to
be a part of this project and I don't
think it's going to happen anymore which
one it's a movie that's gonna be back in
the works and I don't want to talk bad
stuff about it I will tell you off
camera but it's a there's something that
happened and I was like man I really I
wanted to be a part of this for seven
years back in the works
it feels like a clue stopper my mama
will shoot again how do you know I knew
it's twins twins two twins too this time
they're identical this time because the
face swap technology they can put
Arnie's face on Danny davido's body like
God I mean look at me look at my Lads
they're small like I would eat that I
would eat that in between you know
what's that now do Davido this is the
Vito a little now do Arnie eyes on me no
as Danny
but they're both Arnie they're both
Arnie well they're both his voice but
Danny DeVito let me try impossible
hot wings what hot wings I'm sorry I'm
sorry I slapped you Danny Devine I'm
sorry now I'm doing Will Smith doing
Muhammad Ali yeah I'm the greatest
I'm the Millennium
this is wow
I think people don't know me only as
wild wild west and the album Millennium
that's the only one he did no
big Willy style fine y'all in it parents
just don't understand
they don't understand and Mike Tyson I
fought Mike Tyson remember that one oh
yeah one punch is all it took he hit me
in my ribs in my inside Chuck how can I
say this by being discreet let's just
say my ballot's released
he was a clean he was a clean classy
will we ever have another clean
um wrapper again
that's a good question these things
swing you're talking about
of the
I sometimes wonder are we heading
towards
a regression not a regression like it's
bad backwards I mean like are people
going to be like let's just keep it
simple I just want a good time rapper
well they find it in other places right
like like boy bands are back BTS is like
Hispanic world that's right yeah that's
right they're the biggest in the world
yeah and they are a just give me
something like to chew on that's what
I'm saying when comedy was like this
where I was like let me tell you I had a
glass of water really I should say the
glass water had me right the people in
the audience one woman's ear was like
falling off a guy had his last nickel he
decides to eat it he's like just washing
it down with his last sip of Seltzer
everybody had ties that were too short
hands that were made out of hay what I'm
saying is times were rough like times
being rough isn't new right and the
rougher things get the more you want
someone that's just gonna like deny
reality and be like streaks on the China
never met him before like we're gonna
see a lot of this with the hat like that
because we don't want
to go a lot of us don't want to go out
and have people be like you see the
Doomsday Clock it's at 11 59. we don't
like
like yeah just saying the theme
of the themes are Belvedere
streaks on the China
yeah people just don't want to feel like
it's over even though it is
it oh yeah you think I think it's coming
to a close and why are you sweating
anything because I'm I think I need to
go out with anxiety you want to keep
riding it because I feel like like if a
plane is crashing
that you say thanks crashing you're in
it thank you thank you
see there you go and I say knew it
knew it as knew it because all my
anxiety will have it will have come to
fruition pitch called it
we get to the exterior of the plane as
it goes into a mountain
brought to you by Orange Theory these
people aren't doing the crunches
I actually I need to start letting it go
but I feel like my plate is so full it's
stupid I'm putting too much on it well
that's that's the Ohi of it is like when
Sandman yeah yeah when I don't know like
when a little less when a little more
grass and clouds and stars not just Ojai
but like you're oh hi your thing
um I guess I wanted it to be soon
but La is
um a Fickle mistress it's just gross it
does this thing to you but it's so gross
it's like uh you know what Los Angeles
as a city is the is a casino it adopts
the exact same ideology as casinos sure
where they're like come on look at all
the look at all this money and shiny
stuff and you get here and you're like
hey I'd like to play and they're like
come on and you play and you're like oh
my God Seinfeld's like come on
play it you play it and then as soon as
you win even a little bit even a
minuscule amount
you win and you're like I'd like to go
home with some of my winnings and the
casino's like the [__] you will we're
gonna come you're gonna sit here yeah in
a free room yeah and get more [__]
you're like I've got more [__] but
you're losing as you're winning and
you're like kind of feel like I'm losing
all this stuff and they're like come on
you're in [__] me yes baby you're
seeing carrots and sticks I'm gonna tell
you something that's how it feels I did
Montreal and I'm not even putting down
Montreal see I'm even afraid to say this
yeah but I'm gonna say it you Montreal
like the 10th time it's like the tenth
time I've been to Montreal this past
time you just did it yeah yeah it was
fun yeah it was fine it was fun and fine
and I was grateful thank you thank you
okay and you know and then Bruce just
turns off the podcast now he's like
blacklisted
um but then I I remember I won't say who
it was but I remember somebody was
hosting a Gala and I was like I bet you
Sandman that they said I don't want to
go to Montreal I'm done with it because
they've probably been 20 times yeah and
then they said they're offering you a
gal meaning that's what they do you do
it 10 15 times you have your Moment of
clarity where you're like this is a
casino I keep trying to go home with my
money and you go you know what I'm going
home with my money and not just money
but like I'm going home with whatever
experience yeah whatever I need I got
something like I don't mean cash I just
mean all of it right the livelihood and
the experience and you did it you
punched your ticket you rang the bell I
think that's enough maybe I should just
go sit by a [__] River
and they go I shrillberg by the way
shrillberg
this fight is so [__] hot
peeking I swear and I could be wrong but
that's when they go my manager would go
they're offering you a Gala and then you
have to go yeah you know what I'm saying
but you don't no no I'm saying you don't
have to go but I'm saying that's and I'm
not even saying that's how they get you
but I'm agreeing with your point that
there's a certain
you this is what they mean by selling
your soul you come you ring a bunch of
bells you punch a bunch of tickets a lot
of your trains come in and you go like
and now we hear about like Jeff Daniels
lives in like [__] Montana you hear
about there's there's types yeah like
sort of get out
and you're like maybe I'll do that and I
know exactly what you mean then they go
like but we'll but do they have a Nobu
you know what I mean but do they have
the Hollywood Bowl they'll literally
give you tickets you're feeling a little
sad guys she was coming to Hollywood
Bowl Ben Gibbard oh yeah I just said I
don't want to see him did I say bed and
gibbett I said Soundgarden didn't he die
okay that's the thing is they keep
tricking you with whatever they think is
gonna this is back buddy okay so I I
wonder why you moved yeah you got away
from the casino that's it I think so and
I want I wanted to write a book about
how every Everything has like a secret
deep meaning to it and one of the things
is it actually I saw most recently in
Red Dead Redemption 2. but it's a it's a
Trope a video game the video game okay
the game the TV game yeah the TV
handheld controller game the monitor no
keyboard game I love that yeah unless
you play it on a PC and then better yeah
better frame rate
better frame rate my graphics card is
incredible it's a dedicated gaming PC
this is my dedicated pornography PC this
is my dedicated word processing PC okay
in Red Dead 2
um what's his name did you play it no
really you were too busy lifting weights
I don't play video games I don't know
why
you're fine
I'd like to no no stop it okay it's
another casino do you know what I do
instead of playing video games jacket I
sit there sometimes and just think about
it playing video games I'll just sit
there for hours going God I should be
playing video games it's you know you're
kidding but you know what I do now that
I have a baby huh instead of playing
video games YouTubes of other people
playing video games that's so the people
love watching I Love It Esports I don't
I I don't watch necessarily just live
footage of people playing but I'll just
I'll watch like what's that game like
and they just kind of show you it and
I'm like that was my game for today it's
so sad it's actually not sad I'm [__]
43. it's not just my age I've found
other things to fill my life busy not
just busy I'm fulfilled I don't need and
I've also been to therapy I used to play
video games and like go ahead and shoot
a bunch of headshots and I was like yeah
you haven't resolved your [__] with your
dad so you're in Assassin's Creed in a
garden in some Kingdom backstabbing and
freaked everybody you know it's not even
part of the mission because you're like
[__] you Dad I am a man like I put that
to bed I don't need to play that
simulation anymore Yeah the more you
heal the less entertainment there is
that's good you can just sit and be like
I guess I'm a man
here's my boy I think his name is Duke
or dwighter it doesn't matter Duke
people are yelling at their radios right
now unrelated they're listening to those
bad guys and the radio simultaneously
it's so interested
but the the leader of the gang is always
saying one more job and then we retire
you know that this is a Trope in cowboy
movies any villain
the movie The Town we're gonna Rob
Fenway Park and then we retire because
that's how the ego works I'm not trying
to get all Pete holmesley spiritual
about this you do every time I know I do
not every time Katie's been in every
episode she knows sometimes the guest
Homie don't play that anyway but that's
what our ego does we love those stories
because we have a voice in our head that
goes like don't worry baby after Denver
we can finally put our feet up but the
[__] thing is by the time you accrue
enough wealth or means or access to get
that life
all the work you did to get there has
made you addicted to the work you don't
know who you are without it so of course
the rest of your life you'll be 75 going
like one more big jab it's like [__] off
at least be honest be like I'm gonna do
this till I [__] die that would be
more honest yeah I mean when we lie to
ourselves but I might not do it till I
die but that look I'm not saying I
figured out I am saying we did make a
break and I know other people that have
made a break and it's made a difference
and I I think it's I still can come in
and do sets I can still come in and do
this of course but it also but
um when everyone whenever I say where am
I going and then I think well I don't
know what I want to I don't know where I
want to even go like Ojai is a thing you
chose yeah I don't choose Ojai I don't
not I don't not I just don't know if
someone's like throw a dart where do you
want to go
I can't tell you
buddy I think look we're in a similar
place home home I'd love to go home
where's Home Chicago go to Chicago I'm
not going there I can't go there but
that's the thing is I would love to go
there but I'm gonna [__] go in there
that's crazy I don't know There Will Be
Blood yeah if I saw that house I think I
would be sick to my stomach meaning you
can't go home I know because by the time
you do all the things that you did to
get away from home it changes who you
are and you can't go home can't go home
can't go home so let's pick a new place
for me but but what we're talking about
at the beginning of this conversation
and what we're talking about right now
is not just where should we live it's
what do we want where are we going and
and what is the feeling underneath it
you're talking about how the world might
be over and a planes crashing into a
mountain and you're like no Ed you know
what that might be a debilitating belief
because there's like a despondency
that's latching on to you that goes like
who cares I should just grind this out
because it's all [__] [__] of
course I'm stressed out in Denver
[__] sucked I'm reading between the
lines your new special sucks
[Laughter]
but you know what I mean like that's
what Val was good for for me yeah I say
to Val all the time we walk around our
place and I'm like if it weren't for you
I'd still be living in a cop's apartment
in Hollywood just like don't you miss
that cop so far America
everywhere all the time you can take
this home it'll take whatever you want
they don't know how much coke was in
that bag let me tell you something my
nose knows and it's about 50
um but you know peering out our blinds
waiting till our set time
I I get it there's a romance to it but
at a certain point so let's let's figure
it out what is what what do you want to
do what does your wife want to do that's
a good clue
um I know I think we're I think we both
are on the same plane that we do want to
we do want to depart a little bit but we
just don't know where to go we've kind
of kicked around a million different
ideas yeah we jokingly even said go to
New York I was like am I gonna really go
to New York to mix it up just because I
do love New York and why not I don't
know what's the difference I've seen the
T-shirt no well I made those those were
mine those are yours no if you love news
mostly it says whiskey Ginger code uh
whiskey for 10 off I love New York I
heart New York t-shirts add 10 to your
MetroCard but you do love that was you
how many times have you swiped a
MetroCard and it gets it doesn't go and
then you hit your hip on the turnstile
and you look like such a dummy and
that's called the New York bruise what
an idiot I've done live in New York show
me your hip bruise
oh this guy's got a perfect line you
could see it I almost want to push it
and go on the two train
I don't know where I want to go I do
know that
um well do you get energized by do you
like the feeling of being around it I
think I think the real reason I'm having
all this all these feelings post um post
shooting the special is because all the
build up to it and then also being in
the thick I got no time off before we
started shooting the third season of
Dave we're in it now yeah and it feels
overwhelming yeah you're burnt out oh
that's it's all it's just that I mean
I'll feel remarkably different when this
is done I just know me when it's done
I'm just like oh I feel great again yeah
but 14 hour days just gets to you and
then mentally you know you just get
you you you you don't understand mental
exhaustion the way you understand
physical exhaustion as a human it's a
couple of those option I get but mental
exhaustion you kind of don't register at
all until your brain's like and it
starts to break that's right and then
you're like oh my you can't lift
something you go I need to rest but if
your brain is like not giving you the
answer or the directions
you're absolutely right because it's a
different kind of fatigue it's the same
thing with illness when you have the flu
yeah I got the flu I gotta stay home but
if you're like mentally broken it's hard
to recognize you can't take a
thermometer to it and here's what's even
more deep and and kind of scary
even when someone tells you that they
recognize patterns that you're having a
mental um thing you still kind of deny
it yeah because you're like you're in
you're you're doing that you're doing
that I didn't
I don't do that you're saying I'm being
this way and then until you actually
have a point of self-reflection when
something happens Moment of clarity then
you go
oh do I always do that this is what's
helpful with a partner too I don't mean
to say not everybody needs to have a
partner okay some people look at Flying
Solo some people love to play no but it
is they really balance you out it's
really not Val said here's here's my
impression of Val
uh you be me you come home from a set
all right you go just sort of stunk I
don't think I wanted to stand up all
right I'm Pete homes ready go ahead okay
very good very good very well
Minecraft got home from I said and it
was a stinker
and Val just comes in on angel wings and
she's like listen Pete
soft and sweet all right I'll be ready
I just that set was terrible I hated
every second of it
I don't want to do stand up anymore
you're going to have a great set
tomorrow and you're going to come home
and be like stand Up's the greatest
thing I'm never going to stop doing it
you're right let's eat dinner that's it
it is and I need that you're talking
about like here's what we want when a
doctor says you're doing this or a
therapist says you're doing this we do
resist it but if you have a partner
who's watching you all the time and is
with you all the time and goes like have
you noticed you're a pretty black and
white either stand Up's the best thing
in the world or it's the worst thing in
the world you go like [__] I can't say
you're an incredible witness because
you're you're always here you're seeing
all of it you're seeing all but how
often is it black and white or is it
mostly
I love it I love it I love it and then
only sometimes I can't stand it
look I
and for you the last friends show that
you did oh Largo I love you tear the
roof down everyone has a good time
everyone's funny Val and I I told you on
the drive down we were talking about
this and we're like maybe I should mix
it up I don't know what that means I
don't know how stand-up fits into that
but maybe we just gotta shake it up
somehow not just mod modify and change
the levels but really redefine and think
of something creatively exciting for me
it could be a TV show could be something
I haven't done before and I want to do
something different I hear you
and she was like okay let's say just as
a thought experiment you stop doing
Santa
uh [__] Neil Brennan comes and goes I
didn't realize you had started you know
sorry somebody dropped a vegan cracker
back here I'm gonna be full for weeks
why [__] on one of my dear friends for
being but it's so true for being thin
it's so thin he's very thin that's where
the Crossroads restaurant reference
comes from is that you're about to die
we'll see you at the crossroads man you
show up eat it eat a little bit more
vegan food and you're barely making it
out of this place
I really feel like that's only for me
it's for you it's my favorite restaurant
and I'm sorry I don't mean I'm not big
in front of vegans because I know I'm
gonna get a lot of vegan hate online
you're gonna get a lot of hemp
stationery coming to Whiskey Ginger can
you imagine all the vegans trying to
conjure up all that energy to yell at me
but they just don't you know I'm mostly
vegan right I know I'm teasing well you
know but I did I did have eggs this
morning because I'll tell you something
when you go to Ojai and you know the
chicken that laid them you don't feel as
bad about eating see that's interesting
I just don't want to eat those eggs
where it's 300 000 chickens in a box on
top of each other
and they're all cross-sided I'm just
farting out eggs all day long please
make me a meat one but when you have a
normal one but when a normal one just
happened it does it right on your plate
it goes prayer
I think that's true eat up either way to
eat Meats is if you know them if you
know them know them know him also I I I
saw a pig a pet pig a friend has a pet a
friend at a pet pig and
I just I changed everything it made me
shift my thoughts of bacon buddy because
I was like pigs are neat oh yeah and
this is mean but cows
I've never seen a cow where I was like
oh I shouldn't eat meat every time I see
a cow like we gotta get rid of these
[__] things it's possible did I do
this bit in Largo I don't know I was
like there's pigs oh you're the Hooves
Hooves yeah
that's my favorite we don't eat dogs
because they don't have hoops that's the
difference
pause no way cute and especially by the
way that like little little tiny Paws
the way they click I say I think I say
about cows it's too much like us like if
you go it's us if we back down
especially if we just went on all fours
I think there's a Chinese thing where
they're like if it has one leg eat it as
much as you want meaning a plant if it
has two legs eat it you know moderate
yeah if it has three legs what is it
what is it well definitely
please write below if it has three likes
please indicate what it is and if it has
four legs eat it rarely rarely what if
it has five legs I actually think of it
as no legs fishy fish it's interesting
the more legs you have a spider that's a
cholesterol nightmare well yeah I was
just gonna say that's worse than a
couple that's worse than egg yolk
spiders those things are just do you
know the egg yolk spider
when you bite into it just a little
yellow somebody wanted that nobody
wanted that I'm editing that out get it
out get it in my mind and Katie gets it
out no Katie won't get it out Katie is
this annoying to sit and listen to all
this [__]
okay amazing what if oh my God Katie
what if you're over there going like I
need to mix it up yeah she does she's
like I just reinvent I need to like
infinite potential Blue Sky
and then where would you move Katie if
you could move
probably Monterey Monterey oh my God how
beautiful Monterey isn't that what
killed Steve Irwin oh boy
you can edit my Joker
[Music]
you can add it out my job
Monterey is beautiful I could see that I
could say California yeah Northern it's
a anything up that far
between it's like two hours south of San
Francisco it's like by Santa Cruz
it's so pretty man there you go Half
Moon Bay
the the it's a lot of elderly the it is
really I love the elderly I love them no
no they're good to me I did the San
Francisco comedy competition and we did
one show at the half moon but you know
who won it was uh Brent Weinbach before
we ever really like officially met but I
he was like a beloved figure in San
Francisco and I went up there way out of
my league Too Young in the game didn't
know what I was doing and I watched him
perform
oh forget it and I was like I get it I
absolutely get where he is and why he is
and we were all I mean he was relatively
new as well but I don't know if he's
from San Francisco or he's from the Bay
Area
right am I wrong he feels like he's from
another planet
a comedy Planet but he but no I just so
I think it was actually a compliment not
yeah what a weirdo he's so good he'll
give you imposter syndrome well I have
that in Spades but that uh David Spence
yeah Kate oh I have sarcasm in David
Spades okay
foreign
I'd probably say
do you need a help yeah werewolf no
Frankenstein's monster no vampire not
really Creature from the Black Lagoon
now we're getting warmer water yeah
water is yucky weirdos because you're in
like a swamp that's already gross yeah I
swapping you're always about to have sex
these people are always about to like
bone in a swamp well swamps are hot
swamps are hot something about taking
your old lady down to the swamp for a
little poke and choke I like a bot
I like a body of water that can fart
s are always like
I do like I think that might be the
scariest or the creepiest anything water
related
nobody likes it good choice I mean it's
very cool the way that they've
constructed those creatures do make me
afraid of them yeah they look and it's
the classics like 1950s Creature from
the Black Lagoon still is scary now as
it was then yeah but werewolves nah
well werewolf I think is because I know
it's a guy under there we did werewolf
is the fear that deep down you are an
animal right that's the creature the
Black Lagoon is he's just I'm here to
you well he's an experiment gone wrong
you know that's just when yeah when
Halliburton is dumping chemicals into a
pond that's what comes from that's right
so that that's you know that's like wow
that's actually they constructed that
looks like something weird give it I
find Nessie to be off off-putting really
yeah here's what I'm going to say to you
okay I'm gonna put you in a Tylenol
capsule yeah I'm looking at it it's as
big as you
foreign
it's also weighted on the bottom like
like a one of those inflatable things
you box
so you cannot get over it said I'm gonna
drop you into the Loch Ness but here's
the twist nessie's real
and you're just gonna wait in the murky
Darkness for like not scared not scared
first of all a water dinosaur I bet you
not
not scared I bet you a water dinosaur
you're not picturing it big enough she's
a water dinosaur and first of all she's
a female okay so you think you can charm
her well she feels my fear and she
immediately starts to go she emotionally
is gonna be one of these tell me another
creature then I like that that's a it's
inherently a female
Mothra no
werewolf guy yeah Bigfoot guy Creature
from the Black Lagoon guy uh
Frankenstein's monster guy made a guy so
the only one is Ness because old Nessie
is a sentence this is the misconception
that people have that she's this evil
Lake dwelling creature she's just a
sweet leftover from an era
from millions of years ago and she just
wants to live and chill out in roam
that's her oh hi yeah that's her [__]
oi that lake is her Ojai and a bunch of
nerds keep going just leave her alone
leave her alone she got out but the
other ones have real issues yeah the
other ones want to kill you yes she
doesn't want to kill it she's never had
one instance where someone's like then
she wrapped the boat and broke it in
half it did okay what about this yeah
giant squid
I'm gonna say where you are now you're
not in the Tylenol you're on a seafaring
vessel you're only an old old wooden
ship scared out of my [__] mind yeah
too many hands so many hands
it just I it just can do so many things
if you think it's doing this but really
it's coming behind you you'd be like
that I also don't octopus they can lift
you up and look at you while it's about
to kill you yeah yeah as you go towards
that tiny yeah
like that that guy yucks me out an
octopus is the animal embodiment of when
people come up to you and they tap yours
yeah it's so stupid or that it is
they're that so but but I've found a
common theme I'm being serious yeah
these are all man related creepier ones
as long as it's not messy you're afraid
nessie's the only one that I think gives
me actual Comfort if I was lost in a big
big lake yes and Nessie
came up I would try to imitate her to
let her know I come in peace yes kind of
like they did in arrival
yeah
whatever make sure how much respect
would you lose for me if I didn't
understand the end of arrival I did
I'm being real it's really important
that you were lost on it yeah but if I
was like if you and I saw it together
and I was just like I what
I don't understand I bet can I see your
phone and I go to my number and I just
delete my number and hand it back to you
and walk away honestly here's another
question oh wait hold on before we go
forward I have a friend that I have a
friend that touchdown I have a friend
that walked out you guys saw everything
everywhere all at once yes I have a
friend that walked out of that movie
that's that's and and I was in shock and
it changed my ideas of him because I was
like
what didn't you like he's a really like
Keen guy and I was like what is and he's
like I think it was Overkill and then I
started to think was I just sold on it
so much that I didn't notice that it was
Overkill Sandman I'm an agreeable mump
right but
I saw that movie you hated it no you
loved it no you were okay with that yeah
and if Val had said let's go
you know the part I'm talking about when
she's walking past everyone yeah don't
give it away okay yeah
uh and around the time when they're like
the when they're smoking pot yeah
no but the let's just say the round
thing yes yes yes yes yes yes
um if she because it's an overwhelming
movie it's heavy and if Val was like you
know what this is too much I would have
happily gone to Cheesecake Factory
that's a yard house next door no it's no
longer cheesecake where you're talking
about but yeah it's a yard of the
Americana well come on man it's 32 ounce
of beers what are you gonna do what are
you gonna knock at the yard I'll be
right back you guys
the alcoholic is so Charming what are
you gonna not get the 68 ounce beer come
on it's three feet of booze you need it
I'll be back with those poppers can I
say this as someone who stopped drinking
everyone who thinks uh no one knows I've
been drinking yes we do yeah of course
it wasn't yeah yeah but I used to be one
of those people that was like it's my
slippery little secret and it's like no
it wasn't like everyone as soon as
you're like I won't say who it was but
there was somebody uh who was drunk near
me recently and was like do you know
this account dad jokes and I was like
you're drunk like it was immediately
clear
oh boy the way you recoil when somebody
says no what
like you have to back up to think about
it and your brain needs more air time
you put a match in front of them what
it is not weed is also hard to get away
with no actually I I am you're gonna say
disagree I just I'm gonna throw down the
draw four are we playing Uno right now
honestly
I've been around some good friends and I
don't know that they're stoned anymore
and maybe I've lost my Spidey senses
well that's actually quit smoking pot I
also quit brain scam and they were like
stop smoking pot I barely wait really
you had something wrong with the old
Noggin I just wanted to see if I had add
by the way this brain scan uh I've been
talking a lot about it 80 bucks use
promo code you made it weird no it's
actually my point it's prohibitive I
love to say things they're prohibitively
expensive it's just such a fun
prohibitively that's prohibitively
expensive it was like fifty five hundred
dollars oh my god well yeah those
machines out of pocket for sure but like
what the [__] why do you have to be why
do you have to have five thousand
dollars just that you don't need if you
want to know if you have add this is
some [__] is there another way to
find out if you have ADD yeah did you
walk out of everything everywhere all at
once you got 80d you might be a redneck
with anything
if you can't follow this joke you might
be a redneck with anything D it is true
though that you being healthy has
everything to do with how much you can
afford to be healthy I'm going to go
back to our muscle talk yeah if you can
like pay someone to make you work out
and go and get like clean good food yeah
but it's a bell curve isn't it I found
out that people that are making good
money they get in good shape and they
eat very well and they live a good
healthy life and then when they get too
much money yes they get remarkably out
of shape and ugly and gross and sad and
fat and miserable because they have too
much they have everything they've ever
wanted the richest people I know are
some of the most out of shape out of
touch yep because they have time they
have everything they have all the things
they don't need it they don't want it
they're miserable another premise coming
at you give it give it give it uh
I was talking about a fancy friend and I
was like Hey having dinner with them and
I knew that they had had dinner the
previous night with like Elon Musk
that's yeah it might as well be Elon
Musk and you're like how do you compete
with someone who the previous you're
where Elon was now I am just going like
and valsa she wants bunnies like it's
[__] I had the same feeling I had
lunch with Dane Cook penny is dropped
that's what British people say for uh
yeah
spread them [__] you're a [__] little
[__] I know it you [__] bag that's why
you wanted me to come back to this
dungeon
as soon as Katie leaves I'm [__]
pennies dropped pennies drop wait you
and Dane had lunch or dinner Dana and I
had a lunch okay let's wait for
breakfast let me guess yeah
where we went sweet corn Grill
remember where it was it was a good
guess though isn't it it's a good guess
it seems like a middle ground Jones on
third
whatever yeah
yeah no not for me that's probably my
second guess Chinese chicken salad
every time I've gotten is it called
Jones yeah Jones out there Jon every
time I've been to Jones on third I'm
like this sorry Jones on third.com slash
weird for 10 off your bill it's weird to
[__] on a sponsor like this but every
time I've been there I'm like why is
Larry David here I'll tell you exactly
why tell me why places like this have
captivated a there is a subculture in
restaurant in restaurant culture of Los
Angeles where once you've kind of made
it through the time you've lasted long
enough
if you've lasted long enough in this
town There's a subculture where it's
cool to go because it's kind of because
La has no history other than real L.A
yeah but Hollywood has no history in
terms of like you know every [__]
four days there's a new restaurant a new
bar a new thing yeah right so because of
that if you've lasted just long enough
people are like it's cool to go to that
because I used to go to that seven years
ago when I first came here 100 like
counters exactly it the food is not good
you know what's weird about canters not
one Jewish singer
really isn't that what a Cantor is
even Katie yeah and she's chosen I got
it I think it's true do not disturbans
are you Jewish still getting the calls I
know I you know why I knew
because you because I trusted you
you made the most like it you think it's
going to be anti-semitic you flip it on
the right you know I know you're Jewish
because I enjoyed your company
then you have to go hi Andrew Santino
like that's how it goes you know why we
know you're a bunch of Jews that's
reverse Rodney Dangerfield yes you're
the best looking sons of [__] I've
ever seen I understand the safety field
you know why I know you're a [__] Jew
because you're Pleasant Rodney say
safety feel I tell you I get just enough
respect not more than others not less
than some I'm feeling pretty good about
my prospects oh look at that hat looks
good on you genuinely great outfit
nice shirt clearly it does come in your
size Rodney safety field
such a good fun bit Rodney say this is
what's good about when you and I get
together when you and I we can only do
these bits on a podcast you can't do
that live because you'll be so
embarrassed here's
the comedy sir
um what if there was a guy named
Rodney's safety field bring out Anthony
jeselnick
you are correct
do you want to hear my Anthony joke yeah
tell it any chance I get yeah
uh
[Music]
it is it is we'll blank it out Katie can
edit it yeah we'll all vote is this
cancelable okay uh two blacks right away
no what I've done it on the Pod before
and he won't do it and he doesn't like
it
I'm on I'm on I can't do him I'm on the
Santa Monica pier and they had a shirt
this is true that was for sale that said
I didn't ask to be born Mexican God just
likes me more
I said I love it
is it available in white
what do you mean that's a great joke
that's a very gesslick joke that's what
I thought that couldn't be more him it's
the most Jesse it's the most
joke
that is really the most so gentle Nick I
have a beard and a leather jacket right
now
was on the Santa Monica Pier very good
it was selling a shirt said
I saw a shirt to say
I didn't ask to be Mexican born Mexican
I didn't ask to be born Mexican God just
likes me more
I said that's a great shirt
does it come in white fat that was very
good the white was very common white
does it come in white that is that
confirmed that was a gentleman show he
should be doing that joke why wouldn't
he that's a per that's a great you told
it to him and he was like I'm not doing
this you know why he said he won't do it
I want to give you one guess
because you wrote it that's a group
that's probably the yeah that's actually
the real that's the real reason he
doesn't want he said I would never say I
love it or that's a great shirt
and I think it it needs that it needs
like
that's great but why doesn't he just go
well you're yes he says he needs it
because if he just goes straight from
hey I read the shirt it said I wasn't
asking I didn't I didn't ask to be born
Mexican God just loves me more if he
goes right to hey do you have this shirt
in white it loses something you need it
it's a misdirect to go I love it does it
come in white right you could go so I go
to the guy is it available in white he's
not a so I go to the guy guy he's not so
I need to be one more Bridge of like uh
I saw this shirt
and and a seagull flew by and [__] on it
and I said that would look better in
white you know like that
oh you really made that work that would
be it wow you would need one more bridge
to make it more gentleness and then I
would say it does look better and white
is is a bridge too far
you know what I mean yeah it makes it
too it's too uh two proud boys there is
there is a
yeah if you put a dead baby in there
somewhere he would he'd like it a little
bit more if there was like a baby on
fire I'm gonna ask you and you saw this
baby's penis on fire yeah
you ask me what I'm gonna ask you a new
I asked this to Val recently yeah and
then we had a great job I love she's the
best by the way you'll see her on the
way out what a [__] cool gem what a
gem what a like a babe a a a cool chick
a smarty pants and it's fine but smarty
pants not not as in a smart alec yeah I
don't like that those two things get
mixed up me neither smartypants I mean
she's just smart look at her in those
smart pants walking around because she's
intelligent smart alec because Alec is
an [__] every Alec name one that's
not an [__] Sulkin Trebek [__] we
just disproved [__] I asked her rip and
she was like that's got to be one of the
new ones because I have the questions I
ask every time yeah yeah yeah but here
with Andrew Santino returns okay
and I'm sorry I wasn't as good as I
should have been today what are you
[__] nuts Oh Katie knows the way she
looked at me she threw one of those I'm
sick of this idiot can I tell you
something this is a candy look ready
there's a kitty look say a bad joke and
I'll give you a kitty look ready okay
what if I just did your act oh my god do
it
I'm trying to get my wife pregnant but
uh you can't just pump it once you gotta
Pump It Up Super Soaker
that's what Katie does it's a little
laugh and then look away like
no I don't like these guys anymore okay
I can see right through Katie dude she
Katie Katie did Katie Katie did is the
consistent that's with K yeah consistent
quality not with a cake
yeah I don't want too many kids Katie
Katie just saying she's great welcome
back to Katie Katie Katie my show
premiering January 6th on Fox but the
font is too big so it's all you can see
his case
um tell me the question you're gonna
love it I am where are we at in time
112. oh that's great love that group uh
uh I can't go to a minute we went to
minerals 12 minutes ago it doesn't
matter okay it doesn't matter well ask
me the question here's the question no
the minerals will just jump in at some
room
there's always a break point there's
always a break
pardon the interruption weirdos this
episode is brought To Us by our friends
at Blue microphones do you love podcasts
uh sure you do you're in listening to
one right now and maybe you've even been
thinking about starting your own podcast
or maybe you want to I don't know record
an album that sounds fantastic or do
voice over for that cartoon uh series
you've been wanting to upload to Youtube
does this sound familiar well if it does
you got to get yourself a blue
microphone guys studio quality sound
does not have to be a huge huge price
you can make things sound amazing with
blue microphones they've got you covered
for the first years of this podcast
we've recorded many many episodes on
Blues most famous mic the Blue Yeti
which is a USB mic that you can just
plug right into your computer and start
to podcast it makes things so easy and
it sounds great even if you're new to
recording it's the only USB mic I found
with different settings for solo sitting
across from another person and
omnidirectional for when you want to
record every sound in the room which is
super super cool it's made by some of
the same companies that make high-end
Studio mics that abuse that have been
used on lots of big records and Blue's
been around for more than 20 years today
blue is part of Logitech for creators
and they even have a new XLR mic which
is what Val and I use for we made it
weird it's my favorite mic it's the Sona
mic it's just been released it's XLR
which means it's as good as it gets it
sounds incredible and if you want that
next step up from the Blue Yeti it's so
cool to get the Sona XLR mic it's for
podcasting it's for voice over I use it
for so many things in fact I just use it
on my zooms to be the person who sounds
good it's fantastic if you're trying to
do something creative that involves
voice over involves music or is a
podcast you gotta get yourself of a Blue
mic that's what we've been doing for
over a decade now so go to
bluemike.com and use promo code weird
for a special deal on any blue
microphone that's
bluemic.com and show your support of
this podcast this
out to us by our friends at Trade coffee
you know for years I didn't really drink
coffee I used to say I don't drink
coffee I run on anxiety well now I love
it it's one of my favorite parts of my
morning I literally go to bed at night
going I'm looking forward to tomorrow's
coffee and Trade coffee is here to take
your coffee game up to the next level I
don't know why so many people settle for
blah coffee every day with Trade coffee
you can start your morning every day
with something special let me tell you a
little about Trade coffee it's a coffee
Subscription Service unlike anything
you've tried before because they partner
with top independent Roasters to Freshly
roast and send the best coffees in the
country directly to your home or on
forgive on your preferred schedule your
trade experience can be as simple or
sophisticated as you want you can
quickly select from curated collections
by roast flavor profile Brewing method
and more their team of experts do all
the the work taste testing hundreds of
coffees from across the U.S every month
to curate over 450 exceptional coffees
that make the cut it really is pretty
effing cool or if you want something
curated just for you then take a minute
and complete trades coffees trades
coffee questionnaire you'll be expertly
matched with your perfect coffee and a
fresh bag of beans will be on its way I
love this service I love the diversity
trying different coffees I'm really
shocked what a difference a different
Bean can make a different grind or a
different preparation can make and I've
been blown away with the quality and
frankly how these coffees make me feel
and how good they taste takes the
guesswork out of it and makes my morning
ritual that much more special and trade
is the easiest way to get your very best
tasting coffee delivered fresh when you
need it you've got nothing to lose
because trade guarantees you'll love
your first bag if not they'll work with
you to replace it for free so if you
want to support small small businesses
and Brew the best coffee cup of coffee
you've ever made at home it's time to
try Trade coffee right now trade is
offering our listeners a total of 30
bucks off your first order plus free
shipping with 30 bucks off and free
shipping at drinktrade.com weird that's
drinktrade.com weird for thirty dollars
off your subscription to the best
coffees in the country and show your
support of this show thanks to trade
coffee back to the show
tell me what if you hate it tell me
about a great I think I love it even if
you hate it I love it tell me about a
great nap
you took in your life
oh that's really good because it takes
you just to that perfect afternoon where
you slipped in one
you weren't expecting it I think the
best nap
well it's funny I'm thinking of a recent
nap a recent map is great glad you're
napping well I'm thinking about historic
naps like what was a great nap moment
you want to know mine yeah just a jog
yeah
I mean you're a fit guy you're out there
jogging please can't stop please can't
stop only can stop my mind from running
so fast right
knee safety field yeah I keep thinking
of solutions for the environment
I was in college my roommate Chuck
bought this love seat little couch and
uh I watch Bad Boys funny that bad boys
Choice one yeah I'm not into two I know
I was watching Bad Boys one and some
Skittles
um
and I fell asleep watching it it was the
first time in my life I'm very sound
sensitive and I'm a real nap I'm gonna
say it I'm a nap [__] I need like white
noise I need earplugs I need like a
heavy blanket yeah I'm annoying yeah you
think I like being in that [__] no no I
know no I need like pristine but this
was an unplanned
daytime striped love seat Bad Boys loud
dorm
unexpected I just drifted off next thing
I know Tia Leone has already been
rescued the credits are rolling credit
roll Bad Boys is playing and I woke up
and I felt [__] unexpected like I
know I don't drink anymore but it's like
getting drunk unexpectedly is always
better and napping when you didn't you
weren't a nappy yeah and you didn't plan
it and you just went like oh my God I
think it's like seeing a UFO or
something like it's happening it's real
it's amazing and then you wake up and
it's always
ah it's making me excited it's making me
like feel excited about life just to
think that that sometimes it's gonna
happen I mine's a little toxic
but like Britney
I'm a slave for you did she want to be
out of the conservationship
um
[Music]
if you listen to these lyrics I mean
sounds like I'd like to be under your
control daddy is that what she said
I can't handle my own
I I think uh mine is toxic I'm not gonna
lie but so what happens to me is if I
run really hot and the old lady says
you're running hot it means I'm
emotionally kind of wound up and anxious
and she can see my anxiety this whole
thing we talked about before about your
partner balancing nice I do that all the
time I crack my wrist
um it's nice I will crash yeah so
everybody shuts it down it's wild it's
overwhelmed but when I when it when it
happens it feels that's not good because
it's not good for me but it feels
I can't explain the feeling it's like
your nap thing that's good I'll be
panicking freaking out and I'll sit on
the couch and I'll just kind of like
take a couple of breaths and I'm not
kidding it's Apple menu
It's amazing locked um within moments I
I'm out and when I wake up this is
beautiful you're overwhelmed in your
body and with its own intelligence
circumvents your brain's intelligence it
does a hard reboot and goes like I don't
like this and they go and I do I'll
crash and I'll wake up 20 30 minutes
later
say sorry
I immediately I wake up with a sorry I
go sorry sorry I immediately say sorry
because I know that I was Heavy before I
crashed yes yes yes and then I feel
incredible oh my God I have to go take
like a long walk just to like enjoy it
yeah to soak it in a Victory lap oh it
feels so nice buddy okay but it's bad
physically for me I know those aren't
good
those physical crashes can't be good I
don't think it's the crash that's bad or
the the sleep what's happening before a
hand is bad it's a coping mechanism I
think what you're saying I could be
wrong is there must be a healthier
conscious way to deal with this yeah
your naps are
voluntary minor my crashes are
involuntary I think those are Comas yeah
you went into a 20-minute coma yeah or a
Fugue State dude yeah if you can Fuchs
Ken Fuchs Fuchs State there it is
um Val so Jay Larson was in Ojai swung
by it's one of the great things what are
you doing up there it's too much acid
um one's my jail arson uh he was just
swinging by we had uh brekkie and he was
telling me that I mean Penny's dropped
not what it means but he was telling me
I see much more relaxed and happy and
have been for a while and and I'm like
yeah but also this morning I was driving
Leela to school and Val was with me and
I was like I just noticed what you're
saying hot heart yeah and I'm only
saying this because like
I know I can be like right now I'm in my
silly place I love seeing you you bring
it out I mean it's one of the reasons I
love being with you yeah but there's
different Petes and Pete was driving and
Pete was thinking about he had a call at
10 he had a lunch at 12. he had to do
something that was going to take two
hours somehow in between those things
it's gonna be tight then I gotta get to
La I got to do this podcast and we have
this thing after this and I just started
like really kind of spinning out that's
what my thing Val knows as I've talked
about on the podcast before but the
solution I haven't talked about yet the
voice of my what we call it pain body or
my Panic or my just my wound is I'm not
supported I don't have enough time no
one understands how hard my job is I
know it looks fun but I actually you
know Katie knows better than anybody
like we have to bookhead we have to find
that it's all pain in the ass there's a
lot of there's there's like way more
upkeep than you would think yeah and
sometimes I run out of guests and like
we don't have a guest and like that is
one of of my least favorite feelings
anyway so I'll get into my plane view my
Daniel Plainview where I'm like because
I can't make gold Blue Gold Everywhere
Eli right like I just want to murder Eli
Sunday because I'm all rage but you know
it's not really coming out and Val maybe
notices I don't think so she just has
yeah I know she's Nessie yeah
well you have to hun back at her
sometimes
see to my credit old homes he knows how
to feel his rage Panic hot heart
and go and she's to her credit she's a
safe space so I can just say I'm in my
pain body right now I go I don't know
why but I'm in my pain body and that's a
code that means I'm completely
overwhelmed uh if it's hysterical it's
historical so something is going on that
is my past my parents were also just in
town and no joke it takes me about two
weeks to get back to level regular
cruising altitude I actually thought
this I was like they're my kryptonite
then I was like oh my God Krypton was
Superman's home planet the thing that
makes him not super is his home and I
was like the thing that makes me not
super that makes me feel like a child
are my parents then I can't go out to a
theater and be Mr Saturday night after
I've had someone be like you have cream
cheese on your [__] face like like I
feel like an eight-year-old and an
eight-year-old can't fly to Toronto on
October I just like this
so I'm having panic it has probably has
something to do with them being in town
and and you know when you take all that
time off to just be with your family and
now all the work is coming back flooding
in so I'm really panicking
and Val's like it probably has something
to do with your parents and she's like
just picture them saying to you what you
wish they would say to you just imagine
it saying it to your little boy I'm
doing it yeah and this is what I did I
did it right when she said it I pictured
myself in Cape Cod which is where we
used to go on these little trips I just
picture my mom being like you're a good
boy I'm so proud of you I love you so
much you're great you don't owe me
anything thank you for everything you do
you're perfect all that sort of stuff
and for some reason that day that's what
untwisted the rage and I didn't need the
shutdown does that resonate to you child
self stuff
no love it we'll be right back
these minerals because I think with me
it's fun athletic green sorry
Alpha braid Alpha Brain I think with me
it's more like uh I love your honesty
guys I know what well because uh
tell it spit it as they say well because
my parents
you know they my dad texted me on the
day I'm shooting my [__] special I'm
overwhelmed
and they went down to Florida to be with
their friends
which by the way they just got out huge
storm today like insane you know they
just gotta like Florida is a [__]
class five hurricane or some [__] they
just got out on time uh and my dad
texted me on the day
in the morning June my special
made it to Florida and a picture of him
and his buddy on a boat go Vols like his
the Tennessee volunteer he went to
University of Tennessee College Football
Saturday
and go Vols
and it [__] I want to throw my phone
out the car window like go [__] involve
go [__] yourself what do you but like I
just had so much Panic all day I didn't
even need them to see that's what's
different I didn't even want them to be
like good luck on the special yeah but I
didn't want the other thing yeah I'd
rather have nothing because the other
thing to me is more annoying that's like
what
the [__] out of here you and I don't
know what to do with the other thing
yeah if you got like a coherent like
I'll be your dad yeah Andrew I know
you're probably under a lot of pressure
right now I just want you to know it's
going to be fantastic no shut the [__]
up you don't know what to do with that
no well you you you're more comfortable
with go vaults here's a picture of me
with a salmon because I know how to make
fun of it yeah that's right well because
you know this is our Brokenness well
because the other things some people do
have the dead that goes my baby boy is
going to tape us special tonight kill it
but if they did say so proud of you
happy I would have gone no I do know how
to deal with it but it is our family's
different we're like
it's like okay I love you I love it like
it's we're it's not super like uh
effusive
no like I would have been like oh thank
you thank you and that's and we're gonna
move forward yeah
it's like a pleasantry yeah you know so
we're not really big on that like I
noticed that with um
uh I don't know if I'd tell the story
tell it well here it is in shooting Dave
Dave's connection to his parents is is
uh it's like remarkable it's like his
IRL they're just so supportive in real
life yes it's amazing
and in order to get prepared for a scene
he was watching a video from his mom
and I feel like a piece of me is like
Don this is no one else's business but
it was kind of sweet I'm not going to
divulge anymore but it was just like it
was so unfamiliar yes we can keep it
about you it made you feel
um I would never yeah I could never it
sounds like if I needed to do a scene
where I had to break apart
like a giant statue with a sledgehammer
yeah I might hit play on the audio
message from my mother and I'd be like
[Applause]
I don't have the other thing I don't
have the other like uh we just don't
that's just not a part of my history
yeah and it's not a bad thing it's just
different like for me when I have the
hot hot you call it like the heavy heavy
brain
when I'm running hot and she says
my relief is uh
I guess the biggest relief is like uh
just getting better at being like [__]
it I don't care and just pissing away
all like that
all the heavy breasts I'll just sit down
sometimes and come out like this today I
had too many things scheduled I canceled
the thing right before this
and I if I used to get real guilty it
was jury duty it was you can't cancel
that by the way he did it
what do you want to know you won't tell
the Dave video story but you'll be like
this guy this guy definitely did it but
but I canceled something and I used to
feel bad about that stuff but then I
thought you're back to mental health
you're allowed to go I don't really want
to do that I don't think I have the time
to do that yeah that's right and that's
okay but I have to learn to do that
because when I was young and people
pleaser and you're always like me and
for humanoid we're just talking about
this on the phone when you're so afraid
in our business to go I don't want to do
that or I don't feel like doing that
because when you're young you're like
well what are they gonna [__] they're
gonna hate me and I'm gonna be an
[__] and oh he's difficult and you're
like I just sometimes I don't want to do
stuff yeah and I don't want you to have
the ability to like Bully me into doing
stuff and they do yeah and that's the
thing when you're talking about people
don't realize they bully you into things
and you feel like well I guess I'm
supposed to feel lucky to do it so I
guess I have to do it yeah even though
you're like I don't [__] want to do
this that's right so you get older and
you go
I think I'm gonna do that and I don't
feel bad about saying hey man I really
can't do that I'm sorry when I started I
remember watching Aziz Aziz was around
the same time I'd been doing it three
years I think he'd been doing it one
year maybe and I watched this guy
say no to things around me left and
right like not
this I probably told the story before
but probably not in five six years but
it's like we were doing best week ever
which is an old TV show which one and
Fred Graver was the executive producer
ah he sounds like he was 80. yeah Fred
gray Graver yeah it's not cradler
in comes Fred face of death that was his
middle name no but Fred was a great guy
he gave us his uh first prank I have to
back it up I have to bat walk it back
that off right beautiful Fred thank you
Fred he's not around but uh edit that
out but edit it back in that's a Time
glass bet that's what Todd says anyway
um we started doing these shows at UCB
in New York to see if we would do a live
tour and at this point we had only been
on the show two or three times and it
was the kind of show that you got booked
by the week yeah like they would call
you on Monday to see if you'd be on that
week so me I was like a like a dolled up
Dame in 1942. just waiting by the phone
flapping my lashes just waiting for the
phone ring so I meet Fred Graver and I
go into full J Holmes that's my father
and I'm like a politician I'm like hello
Mr Gray well wonderful to me thank you
for this opportunity what a what a
thrill best week have a great show great
show just so happy to be here happy to
be a part hope this tour is a success
would love to go on the road for you sir
he goes up to Aziz who's right next to
me like minutes after he did I don't
want to do it no no
no thanks I'm out what Randy he didn't
do any of that but Fred goes up to his
ears
and I'm like curious because azizian is
in the same position as me yeah it's his
first TV thing basically I guess
here's the big dog I swear when Fred is
shaking aziz's hand Aziz is already
turning away from him before Fred has
released his grip it was like
it was like Bob Dylan in 62. you know
Bob Dylan would just like not look at
reporters and be like yeah I like
playing a ton what can I say and he just
rolls into a pool it was like either the
coolest thing in the world or the most
disrespectful or just or maybe it was
just like this this dude's so anxious
that he doesn't know what to do it could
be anything right but it wasn't what I
was raised to do I was raised Mr big is
here how you doing sir and then and then
after that disease they wanted him so
bad and then he backed away from the
show he ended up doing other things and
I was like oh there is another way to
play it which is the but I think it has
a lot to do with it that all the only
certain people can do it because some
people miss it depends on who you are
and your energy and your physicality
there's so many elements that go into
this the the the nuances of that you're
a big guy you're tall yeah your attitude
is domineering people may think you're a
dick or you're being a jerk is this how
you tell me yeah
wow but like people say this often to me
like a fan will be like oh man I thought
you were you know like a lot of times
sometimes people will be like hey I know
you don't want to be bothered but it's
like I don't it's a physical projection
people think because I'm strong I'm like
I say strong personality that people
like I don't know he probably doesn't
want me but Aziz is a smaller guy and
he's kind of quirky so it goes along
with he can get away with if in fact he
was being an [__] yeah it can be
misinterpreted as oh he's just nervous
next you want to get out of there if you
and I do that because of personalities
it's like he's a [__] dick so when I
say there's other ways to do it I just
think
I've seen guys Gerard Carmichael is a
great example I remember Gerard
at the store
being so like Whimsical about it it was
like it was like everything was like
ow who knows yeah I don't but he knew I
just feel
I don't
I don't know and then people just absorb
that as like Gerard's perfect yeah
disposition it was strange and and it
was real to him but like to you and me
it's just it's not natural so whenever I
see those things whenever somebody says
no all the time or whenever someone like
they're like credited for these moments
that you're like we couldn't do that I
just have come to the understanding I'm
like yeah because I'm not built I'm
that's not what I am built like yeah I
just look my physical in line with the
story that's already being told as
they're approaching like if Kyle Kinane
was like super Eager Beaver you'd be
like this is something's wrong yeah you
want Kyle to be like
yeah it would it would [__] you off if
it was the other way if Kyle acted like
me everyone would be like kill that this
guy out of show yeah let's murder that
guy
I think you have to match everything and
I don't think you know that when you're
young I think when you get older you go
because Bob Dylan was a little squirrely
and that's who he was no no seriously
his physical was that that's what I mean
he's like he looked like a guy I don't
have the time of day and I don't have a
day for time
someone's like is that a hit record Bob
Someone Like Us yeah I think we should
put that on vinyl exactly and we do make
a lot of money off of it Bob that's just
to be fair and Bob doesn't care and be a
great thin tie record executive let me
tell you something Bob let me tell you
something about it
that's a hit get the girls
wake the girls then the girls are always
there they're always there wake the
girls they're me who's sitting by the
phone get in tune
but we had we're not privileged in that
way that cool we have that thing I think
that just goes along with all the things
I've ever known as when I meet people
and I go right that lines up Katie is
whether you if you never saw her before
and somebody passes her on the street
immediately looking at her physically
someone would go I bet you she's nice I
bet you she's nice
they see you on the street and they go
keep your food and cookies away from
this I was giving you I was giving you
room for the joke the food and cookies
away from his face see what I mean it's
like they immediately people are going
to make the judgment and if you don't
you can either go with it or go against
it and it's hard to go against that's
why I remember there was this guy I
started comedy with name uh Nathan
trenholm and very funny guy and he was
short and he had glasses and he went out
when he did premium blend and I swear he
stood there just looking miserable for
30 seconds before he started and it
killed yeah he was just like
but here's here's another side of that
one time I got huge last year suggesting
the mic and be like
like real people well you do have a Pete
Holmes face
if I understand that happened I was like
this is the greatest thing but you do
you beat goofy Pete home's face it's a
part of your face it's my face that's
why you're able to sell tickets in
Toronto Toronto October 8th guys come on
October that's why you're able to sell
Wackadoo [__] because you're like if I
get too wacky on stage
people almost don't buy it a little bit
I know what you mean yeah it's like well
is that which I love when you're a silly
Billy I like to be a silly boy but also
I no silly I can't so that's that's too
silly that was that is it's a little too
silly For Me Silly Billy silly boy is
fine
and we've seen Silly Billy silly boy
that's right yeah we'll be right back
athletic greens I'm going to have um a
beautiful dinner tonight with one of my
oldest friends and boy oh boy I can't
wait who is it my buddy James from
Chicago I love him so much what if
you're like Bill Cosby yeah he got out
this is should I not be telling people
about that uh my buddy James and it's so
funny because uh
he's home that's home and
it's you're gonna have a great time well
just nice
he's a guy that I wish I ate more food
with
but I just don't see people like that as
much which stinks because you just don't
you don't you know maybe you're an
Evanston guy you want to move to
Northern suburb of Chicago yeah if I
move out of Chicago just like we said in
New York we were looking at a place in
New York and it was like this whole idea
of like well do we want to you did you
got that far yeah where where in New
York well that's what I'm about to tell
you that's the funny part is I said
well I'm not going to move all the way
to New York to not live in New York so
I'd probably live
downtown somewhere you know like
I don't know I really like
I mean Soho would be incredible or
anything down there you know would be
kind of nice cobblestone street I just
want to live in the I like downtown a
lot for some I really like or as close
as I can get throw me over to Dumbo or
you know something like that but sure
I was like yeah because the joke was
like oh should we go out there and see
like a nice house and I was like no we
have to live in the guts of the thing if
we're gonna go we should live in the
belly of the Beast yeah why else would I
go yeah we already live in the you know
sub the suburbs here yeah
um in Pacoima put my address right here
Katie if you can I run my address slash
whiskey Ginger yeah but I just I I feel
like if we were gonna go I'd want to
live inside of the machine I would want
to live give me all the yeah give me the
give me the [__] New York give me New
York were you just grabbing New York by
the big ass by the Apple
and it's got a Crest it's got an apple
ass
but maybe but maybe New York
I think it might be a good way to also
read reconfigure my artistic uh Drive
because our New York is just different
the vibe of stand-up and comedy and art
is just different than it is well did
you have you ever lived in New York no
to spend chunks of time because if you
walk from one set to another set you
have a new bit by the time you get there
I know it's what's so so what's so nice
I just I just know that
I just know just be a New Perspective
definitely changes the way you deliver
comedy even when I when I go there and I
perform I just I like I did the seller
when I was just there
even just going there I immediately am
like
I'm telling jokes a different way yeah
the same joke it's just I'm telling them
different I know what you mean yeah I
feel that way about the store actually
well there's certain jokes I do a joke
at The Improv or something and then I'm
like it's funny when I do it at the
store this isn't this will make sense I
bet you I go I Almost Do It Like I'm
chewing gum
there's like more attitude there's more
fearlessness because at the store
there's just a feeling of like
show us your wares like your weirdest
your dirt that's what I love the seller
feels exactly like that I agree that's
what you're doing it's like a
and then you've I and I love Largo more
than anything if I could only perform at
Largo that would be totally great for me
but there is sometimes I if I do the
store the night before Largo and then I
go to Largo and I like I have a line in
my ACT where I call jokingly obviously
Val a low blood sugar [__]
you made me feel bad about it yeah you
should that's bad
she have died she's just like if that's
your sandwich at Subway you are a low
blood sugar [__] that's true okay okay
so I'm not just saying you low blood
sugar and you know this low blood sugar
[__] I'm living with I don't even know
what pejorative means I'm saying it in
the pejorative sense I don't know what
that means the audience knows nobody
knows Google it email it to yourself
then when it comes in Market display
Market is Spam flag it and I did it at
the comedy store and they were lighting
mattresses on fire they were doing
backflips people were screaming low
blood sugar woman had a baby a woman had
a baby she was like I didn't even know I
was pregnant because they were filming
that show at the time that's a giveaway
if the crew for I Didn't Know I Was
Pregnant was following you you might be
a redneck but I then I go to Largo which
is a nice place people might even put on
a jacket to go to Largo oh they go you
low blood sugar [__] and people are
like hmm not so sure about that one so
it takes all different but you go to The
Cellar low blood sugar low blood sugar
[__] also but but uh in the cellar it's
uh
you you yeah are you a sugar-free [__]
that's what I mean what do you mean it's
like the same joke but a different
spin-on oh you're gonna say it even yeah
you might say it a little bit different
but it's kind of you're trying to say
you're fine Keith
what are you gonna do but he's up there
you're gonna do he's supposed to say
You're Gonna adapt have you ever did I
ask you this last time you did have you
ever almost died
many many many many many times pick one
I was right in the back of a truck at
the bed of a pickup truck when I was in
college oh yeah I am the truck
you're riding in the back of a pickup
truck in the bed of a pickup truck just
flying down why do they call it a bed
anyone's you're not sleeping back there
and a cab a cab is a cab why is the cap
of a truck a cab there's a cab in the
front a bed in the back
like he drank from the wrong
uh Last Crusade why does it start at 150
Ford F-150 250.
you made 149 of these before you came up
with this one
I mean can you imagine by getting mad at
us for doing these bits on him so mad
what are you doing it I uh I paved the
way for you you pave away you take away
and what are you using to pave anyway
asphalt concrete what's more stable
don't be an [__] he's becoming a
civil engineer as we continue on
Seinfeld in other jobs
we need to move units
diversifying any of your portfolio at
all there's a lot of organic Synergy
happening what does that even mean I was
in the bed of a pickup truck coming back
from
Mexico into South Padre Island Texas on
spring break with some friends I was
intoxicated I'm not proud of this moment
the gentleman driving the truck was
intoxicated I'm not proud of that moment
and we caught hitched a free ride from a
man we don't know but I know he had been
drinking I probably definitely knew
and the truck was bouncing around over
this bridge rickety bridge going from
Mexico to South Padre Island
and I sobered up because I mean for a
hot second because we swerved a little
bit because that truck had been pulled
over on the side of the road and we
almost clipped it
and I realized this hits I fly out of
this thing and either ping-pong my head
against some of the bridge iron before
falling in before falling into the ocean
or I fly out of the back of this thing
onto this narrow two-lane bridge and get
immediately run over by a Cascade of
cars
and it [__] me up I held so tightly
onto the sides just like wishing to the
universe that we would make it okay and
it was one of those things where yeah
but the whole time
I kept thinking this is it I am going to
die like this like it was us just
clipped missing clipping that car and
swerving yeah was the
I I it was a wake-up call for I could I
was like I should never get in these a
car with someone who's been drinking
again I didn't know but we did know do
you know what I mean oh yeah it was so
back to my observation yeah you know dad
jokes right there the neck whenever the
neck goes back they're drunk somebody
Josh Ruben told me it's when their eyes
go before their head so say something to
me
have you been drinking tonight sir oh my
God they follow
Joshua it is because the eyes are still
working at full speed yeah the eyes
aren't drunk but the body is the body's
drunk the eyes are like oh God he's
drunk no we have to take care of all
this over it looked that way
good boy
good boy all right now close your eyes
for a second oh my God how much of life
is you just want to be babied and
getting drunk you need to be a baby do
you need help you need someone to be
like do you need a burrito buddy like we
love it yeah well in the morning you're
hungover and someone's like you need
another burrito yeah I want two
yeah I want all of life is actually
trying to get back to the feeling of not
knowing anything yeah you're just like
how can I get back to not knowing much
yeah and that's how you get you've
you've put away all the things and then
and then you want to use abuse stuff to
feel like you don't have to think about
them anymore and then when you sober up
you move to Ohio and you think about all
of them
you'd think my mind would be racing up
there but I have no problem no no I mean
you think about all the things but from
an from uh oh from A New Perspective
yeah from very introspective now
the spiritual thing here but here I go
being conscious but with no thoughts is
a Heavenly State you're there right now
am I doing it right now I'm thinking
about this interview I'm Sisyphus
you're pushing that rock I keep pushing
I I'm gonna stop soon but I am pushing
yes Sisyphus has to put that rock down
and just go like it doesn't this [__]
Hill is so big what am I the Seinfeld's
next to him you'll never get it up there
that's a huge hill and what will you do
once it's up that'll fall on the other
side is that a part of Sisyphus though
that he kept pushing the rock up the
hill and they never make it but he never
makes it but but was there ever a
conversation about once he got it up
there is there a other side to it or is
it a crescendo is there a is there a
summit and why does he want it up there
that was the other thing what was it is
it flat up there I remember Alex Gray
the how funny it's just a little tilted
he gets it up there and it sits and he
stands next to it but for a second yeah
and then it rolls back now you're
designing a good hell yeah it's like let
them think and then and it has to roll
over his foot and now he has to do it
jumping up and down of course Alex Gray
the Psychedelic painter uh you've
probably seen his stuff yeah it doesn't
matter
um he he had a trip or a dream I think
it was a trip where he saw Sisyphus and
and the trip like zoomed in on his face
so here's a guy pushing the Boulder and
it zoomed in on his face and showed that
there was a little smile and he called
it the smile of Sisyphus and I think
that's right on I think even the things
we hate we secretly love oh yeah yeah
you even you when you were little
little eight-year-old Santino going back
would have loved to have been like I
just I take my special my dad's texting
me now I gotta [__] go oh Dave I'm
shooting Dave 14 hour days when you were
little you used to walk around and be
like 14 out like you wanted to be
stressed out so badly I love it I still
do love it no that's why I said I'm not
accusing but I enjoy it so much but that
it is you you feel like you're I'm
pushing a little bit of a boulder
sometimes you're like well no actually
you know what it is it's if you zoom out
a little bit
I'm pushing a boulder when you zoom in
on on my Acid Trip you realize it looks
like it's one but it's 20. 20 Boulders
yeah and they're all kind of I'm like
I'm actually going like this like trying
to make sure they all stay
yeah like a pyramid of them exactly yeah
okay like to me it's like I feel that's
what I feel like that I'm wrong it looks
like one but [__] me it's way too many
I see and if I just patted one rock up
the hill I'd probably get it up there
like just Dave but you're like I'll also
film my special right and do two
podcasts and develop this show
yeah it's just that the Chicago land
[__] James yeah my boy oh sorry he's
your boy he's a he is a prince of a man
I bet he is I'm picturing him a
wonderful story too a man who rode dirt
bikes
and then professionally did like tricks
on them and all that [__] and then also
almost died met his wife who almost who
had a friend die in front of her face
that's what got her to quit they were
both like
trickster oh someone died riding dirt
bikes yeah he met his wife I think they
were on motorcycles I think this was
motorcycle times
I met his wife and they were doing when
he was like touring the world doing
tricks the cigarette of Transportation
100 yeah circus bikes going to kill you
but hey when you have a GoPro on your
helmet for the case coming up where you
have to press you're wearing
your head is decapitated but they still
have it on the helmets like we can't get
the GoPro off so we brought the head in
look at the shock on his face he clearly
didn't see this coming speaking of loose
heads I can't uh I kind of get him out I
got out of my brain because I watched
Dahmer and
the monster on Netflix it's like one of
the biggest what why do you work at you
did you watch it Katie it's it's it's uh
it's just dark because Evan Peter's a
great [__] actor boy oh boy does he
do a good job and he's got like a very
subtle Wisconsin accent um I mean he's
doing Joe Pera you know Joe Pera yeah
yeah he talks to me oh yeah it's great
that thing it's a literally it's
literally Joe Joe Perry Joe para
decapitates you it's Joe para like every
time I see it I'm like this is and he's
blonde and his hair Swift down let's get
you to your thing okay yeah what time is
that it's about time oh 6 20 Daddy's
Gotta Go Daddy's gotta how do I end this
with Pete um
like how do you get out no how do I end
this how do I need to let you go old
Petey usually asks the hardest time
you've ever laughed
um you've done the Pod before and you
already I know I remember the other one
that I named last time what's what's
another hard time I've ever laughed
maybe with James
you could also answer this
anything unexplainable psychic ghost UFO
what if they're both the same thing and
it's the hardest laugh yeah have you
ever had like a psychic tell you
something and you're like I've never
been to a psychic
never been to a psychic I've never used
never seen any of us saying cine ghost I
think we talked about ghosts I seen a
ghost in my buddy Tyler's basement
that's good hosting and then what's the
other thing I'm trying to think of I
didn't sound familiar does that sound
familiar to you I think you did it on my
show I think we came on my show we
talked about well nobody's watching that
that's correct
uh promo code uh get help if you're sad
at betterhelp promo code whiskey making
me sad on your shelf
um I want to think of the heart one of
the another hardest time I've ever
laughed was I don't want to think about
the ghost one thing about the ghost I
think ghosts uh
Great Ghost chains translucent beautiful
ghost
they were both it was the ghosts and the
hardest I've ever left were happening at
the same time really
yeah oh no always I saw um do it again
if you're a real ghost do it one more
time right now if there's actually a
ghost in here do it now
now
now you can make ghost things happen at
your level whenever you need them you
can always find a ghosting like if I go
oh yeah if you're in here do nothing
[Music]
you see
they're there they're tempting us that
is so they're tempting us make ghostings
your own that's what I figured out about
those ghost shows they'll go
did you hear that you can make anything
be a your thing anything was I did here
oh I heard that
did you hear it people will start to go
I I heard I heard it yeah that's true
it's like a fart where you're like oh
immediately someone will go oh is it so
oh yeah yeah you want it to smell
because you want to be a part of a fart
that's not there uh the old Eddie Murphy
bed yeah he goes you want us you want us
to smell you want to smell it because in
the back of your mind you want to grade
the fart yeah yeah you can have the
story remember that fart you made it
made made remember that part you made
how far you made what's the hardest I've
ever left is probably
um recently
oh God that's so hard man I that's tough
that's tough how about this all ended in
a better way
you want to sing a song at the same time
uh yeah you want to follow me or I'll
follow you I'll follow you what's the
song called Katie
doesn't matter Katie's oh God I don't
know
oh sweet Lord
I don't know what the [__] is going
down trickster trickster
have you ever open up your cupboard and
there's a dead cat smoking
cigarettes and he looks at you and he
says I'm not dead I'm actually made out
of jelly beans you're not singing with
me you're not even
try
here
he went up and went down
keep aggressive keep it crispy
[Laughter]
you said it so All-American keep it
crispy
that's a catchphrase keep it crispy
that's how we had Zaxby's keep it crispy
we're done show's over I love you I love
you
bombas thanks for not canceling
please I would never I had to point you
did twice I had to push that's not
canceled
cancel means you don't make it push
means you got to change it
[Music]